bien ya desmonte las dos cámaras del
mismo modelo y honestamente tuve algunos
problemas ya que desmonte la primera
para identificar las partes en su
interior y después tuve problemas en
volver a acomodar las en su lugar porque
algunos tornillos ya estaban desgastados
y no podía volver a colocarlos en su
lugar así que compré otra y descubrí
algo realmente interesante muchos
productos pasan a través de diferentes
modificaciones que no necesariamente
muestran un número de modelo eso podría
significar que el fabricante encontró
otra manera o una manera más económica
de producir algo o bueno simplemente una
manera más barata de fabricar un
producto y así son capaces de mejorar
sus márgenes de costo así que como esta
cámara es de bajo presión estoy seguro
que sus márgenes son de gran interés en
su fabricación ahora por aquí observa
que esta dice que es una versión 3.8
mientras que esta de acá dice que es una
versión 3.3 por lo tanto es una versión
más vieja esta versión tiene una unidad
central de procesamiento
cp un cubierta por una resina epóxica en
cambio la otra sólo tiene una cubierta
de plástico sobre ella la cual no es tan
robusta y parece no ser tan estable al
menos no tanto como la resina epóxica
por lo que será mucho más fácil
estropear estos cables claramente las
placas son de un color totalmente
diferente creo que esto permite el
fabricante saber que son diferentes
versiones y si volteamos las placas
podemos observar y para esto voy a
acercar un poco la cámara pueden ver que
el dispositivo de carga acoplada o el
dispositivo que capta la luz es muy
diferente este se ve más largo y robusto
y este se ve más pequeño lo que aparenta
que hicieron una reducción en los costos
probablemente esa fue la razón incluso
la memoria integrada es de un fabricante
diferente observa tal vez la nueva
memoria sea menos costosa otra cosa que
puedes observar es que esta placa no
necesita este capacitor quizás sea
porque este capacitor electrolítico era
una manera económica de almacenar carga
al momento de tomar una fotografía
y si miramos los lentes este tiene una
gran cubierta y este otro no tiene
ninguna cubierta probablemente porque
era un costo adicional no creo que sea
propiamente lente lo que cambiaron lo
que supongo es que es la misma pieza
pequeña la pieza que vemos dentro pero
se ve más grande con esto y tal vez
simplemente lo desecharon para reducir
costos en fin estas son las diferencias
entre la primera o bueno una de las
versiones anteriores y las versiones
posteriores y curiosamente el consumidor
no podría apreciar las diferencias ya
que ambas cámaras son virtualmente
idénticas por fuera